Known as the father of modern fantasy
is epic tales of legends and Law.
I've been enjoyed by millions of people
all over the worlds devoured and popular
books and adapted for
Hollywood blockbuster films.
Unbelievably Bright.
He was a distinguished
university professor,
poet,
historian,
and experts,
linguist as a trials.
He even made up his own
languages for pure fun.
He gave us a complex
and fence for creatures,
including hobbits,
orcs and elves sat in a
prehistoric middle laugh.
Some theorize that is made up.
Worlds are symbolic of his country's
past power struggles influenced by his
devout Roman Catholic faith or simply
the genesis of his personal experiences.
In any case,
there is no denying his
glorious imagination and his
rightful place amongst the
greatest writers of all time,
but who was the creator of the
hobbies and the Lord of the Rings?
Well,
today on biographics,
we explore the life of Jane are talking.
Yeah.
Before
bank clerk after talking and Mabel
Suffield welcomes their son into the world
via English couple moved to South Africa.
Here,
Alpha had high hopes of advancing his
career and providing a comfortable life
for their budding family.
John Ronald rule known as Ronald to most
was born in Bloemfontein South Africa
on January the third 1892 not
long after another son Hillary.
He was born competing,
the talking family,
talking his childhood in Africa.
It was cut short when his mother decided
the boys would be better educators and
then native England's at the age of
three Talkin and his mother and younger
brother left for their homelands.
Well,
Arthur stayed behind
to settle the business.
He was planning to join them but never
meters falling ill and dying of these
severe brain hemorrhage,
a complication of rheumatic fever on
February the 15th 1896 at the time the
spread of disease and contagions were
fears and to travel took many weeks if not
months off.
His body was laid to rest
without his family by his side.
Having spent just a small fraction
of his early years in Africa,
talking had very few
memories from that time.
However one tail persists,
but the facts remain uncertain
according to this story.
The then toddler talking stumbles upon
and was bit by a baboon spider type of
tarantula in the garden.
Talking,
ran,
screaming,
and it isn't as immediately snatched him
up and just suck the venom out from the
wound.
Talking later said he could remember a
hot day and running and fair through long
dead grass,
but the memory of the tarantula itself,
faders and he sad that the incidents
left him with no special dislike of
spiders.
Still fans and armchair psychologists
to like speculate whether the tarantula
influenced the presence of man eating
spiders talkings later fictional works
well back in England's Mabel in the
boys settled with family in the West
Midlands first and King Seeth Ethan.
Then in cell hole on one hands,
and especially in the city of Birmingham,
the West Midlands was urban,
dark and industrial.
On the other hand,
it was the idyllic English countryside
with lush green trees and a corn mill in
the rural hamlet of [inaudible] between
the ages of four and eight talking lived
across the street and within 300 yards.
If the sat whole mill and Mosley bog,
he spends many hours that playing with
his younger brother and being chased by
the Miller's son,
whom the boy is nicknamed the white.
Oh,
the Shi'a Tompkins imaginary land
of hobbits was inspired myself.
A hole in the hobbit.
He writes of Bilbo Baggins running as
fast as his fairy feet could carry him
down the lane past the great mill across
the water and then on for a mile or
more tokens.
Mother homeschooled the boys at first
to teaching the young Tolkien botany ans
the basics of Latin talking could read
fluently by the age of four and to write
soon after he loved drawing
landscapes and trees,
but his favorite studies where
those involving languages.
Later he would attend King
Edward's school in Birmingham,
which proved to be the perfect breeding
ground for the boys is natural curiosity
and developments of linguistics.
Talking was an exceptional student.
He was capable of easily mastering ancient
and modern languages including Greek,
Latin,
Spanish,
old English,
old Norse,
Gothic,
and finish the boy.
He made up his own languages
including early variations of elvish.
Once featured in his
writings asking Edwards,
he made a number of close friends
and formed a semi secret society.
Let's enjoyed drinking tea and
critiquing each other's literary works.
They called themselves TC bs,
which stood for the tea
club Barrovian society.
Despite the earlier loss of his father.
Life of the [inaudible] was generally
happy until two events altered the course
of his life.
In 1900 his mother decided to
convert to the Catholic faith,
this ball to move left and Mabel and her
son's estranged from both sides of the
family and in the fall.
Laos talking experienced isolation,
loneliness,
and poverty.
Following his acceptance and some Catholic
church talking remained devout in his
faith for the rest of his life.
He has also been credited with being
partly responsible for bringing another
famous writer and friends.
Cs Lewis spect,
Christianity.
Tragedy.
Then struck talking again in 1984 when
his mother was diagnosed with diabetes.
A sure death sentence in that time,
sadly,
Mable died in the same year on November
the 14th talking was 12 at the time.
Fortunately for Tolkien
and his brother Hillary,
that Catholic priest,
Father Francis Morgan stepped in and it
became their guardian and made sure the
boys received everything they needed
both materially and spiritually.
Talking mess.
His eventual bright brass when he was
16 and she was 19 they were both orphans
and lodges at a boarding house run
by a woman named Mrs. Faulkner,
the two group funds of each other and
a friendship developed and then as it
happens with teenagers,
the patter came too
close for Father Francis.
His liking.
He was horrified as ward was courting
a Protestant women and to believe the
relationship was a distraction from
talking school work for other Francis for
Bates,
talking to see your corresponded
with Edith until he was 21 this was a
devastating blow to talking,
but he obeyed the order.
When his birthday approached,
he wrote to his love and
his proposed marriage.
Her reply was heartbreaking,
but offered a glimmer of hope.
She was engaged to another man,
but his latter,
NATO reconsider.
Edith agreed to meet talking on January
the eighth 1913 at the train station in
Shelton.
They walked and talked for
hours and Edith accepted tokens,
marriage proposal,
breaking off her prior engagements.
You just converted to Catholicism and
the couple married on March the 22nd 1916
[inaudible] was 24 years olds and a few
months shy of deploying to the western
front in all.
That's it to his son,
Michael.
Years later talking expressed admiration
for his wife's willingness to marry a
man with new job.
There's more money and to know prospects
except the likelihood of being killed
in the great war.
Talking was a true romantic
and Edith was his muse.
He wrote to her,
oh,
how was raven a skin clear her eyes
brighter than you have seen them and she
could sing and dance talking.
We're so mad for if he
created the fictional power
of star crossed lovers based
on their romance Lithion daughter.
If the Alvin King of Dory
F and Barron a mortal man,
they fall for each other.
When baron discovers Lithion
singing and dancing and a glade.
Yet that love can never be
since baron is destined to die.
Alas,
disapproving father,
the King Sends Darren on the task.
He knows the mat and cannot
complete the full story of Leith.
Ian and baron was left unfinished
during [inaudible] lifetime,
but it served an important backstory
and the hobbit talking son Christopher
later published Lithion and
baron is a chapter in the saga,
the Silmarillion Edith and Toki and
enjoyed a long and happy marriage to each
other and they had four children,
John Francis,
Micheal,
Hillary,
Christopher,
John,
and Priscilla.
Marianne [inaudible] was a devoted
father and his loved his children,
often making up funds for stories for
them from 1920 to 1942 at Christmas time,
talking illustrated
letters to his children,
introducing new characters
such as the north polar bear,
snow man and others.
Three years after his death,
these intimate stories were published
as letters from Father Christmas by the
Tolkien estate
believing he was in his own words,
a young man with too much imagination
and little physical courage.
Talking did not rush to join the
British military when war broke out.
Instead,
he returned to Oxford where
he had achieved a first
class degree in June of 1915
Tolkien was busy working on poems and
his invented languages at this time.
Eventually though,
talking enlisted as a second leftenant
in the Lancashire Fusiliers and was sent
to active duty on the western front just
in time for the battle of the Somme,
also known as the Somme offensive.
The Battle of the Somme remains one
of the bloodiest military battles in
history.
It lasted for long months
and on the first day alone,
British troops suffered over
57,000 casualties in total.
Over a million men lost their lives,
including 420,000 British soldiers
fighting in the great war,
talking witness the horrors of trench
fighting and lived in deplorable and
sanitary conditions.
It was hell on earth for Tolkien and his
comrades who stood by as their friends
suffered and died them.
They spend their days and nights with
little relief and endured infestations of
lice that feasted on their flash.
As a result,
talking came down with trench fever,
a major medical problem of world war
one so severe with a licensed captain
staying with talking's units.
Later recalls we dos down for the night
in the hopes of getting some sleep,
but it was not to be,
we no sooner lay down than
hordes of lice got up,
so we went round in the medical officer
who was also in the dog house with this
equipment and t gave us some ointments
which he assured us would keep the little
bricks away.
We anointed it ourselves all over with
the stuff and to gain lay down in great
hope,
but it was not to be because
instead of discouraging them,
it seems to act like a kind of hoarder
of the little beggars went at their feast
with renewed vigor,
sick and is unable to fight.
He's talking left the battle front to
recover in a Birmingham Hospital in
November of 1916 through 1917 and 1918
talking had bouts of the illness and he
spent time in remission doing service at
home and at various camps talking most
likely escaped death on the battlefronts
precisely because he became ill,
sadly all but one of his close friends,
including those from the tcbs
perished in the war as a writer.
This tragedy of loss and firsthand
experience in battle provided.
Talking with a keen sense of
awareness from the unpublished,
the book of loss tails talking,
writes in huts full of blasphemy and
smart or by candle light and bell tense,
even some down in dug outs
on the shelf in the hobbits,
the battle of the five armies.
It's thought to draw upon talkings
wartime experiences as well as the dead
marshes and black gauge of
mortar in the Lord of the rings.
On November the 11th 1918
the armistice was signed,
which marks the end of World War One.
Duncan was appointed
assistant lexicographer Ron,
the new English dictionary,
also known as the Oxford
English dictionary in 1918
but stayed on the job for
only a short while.
In the summer of 1920 he accepted a
post as a reader with the University of
Leeds Leeds.
He taught and collaborated
with other authors,
continued writing the book of loss tails,
constructed languages,
and founded reading and social
clubs like the Viking club.
This was an undergraduate club for
Stevens who had an affinity for old Norse
Sagas and drinking.
Yeah.
In 1925 talking that finally
received his professorship at Oxford.
The Rawlinson man's
Bosworth professorship,
Anglo Saxon talking,
was right at home in academia and fit in
remarkably well with the predominantly
male culture.
He reveled in the lectures,
research and exchange of ideas with
students and fellow professors.
Talking did not publish many scholarly
articles yet he was extremely
influential.
One lecture worth mentioning altered
the modern study of the old English epic
tale,
Baerwolf and twist first
delivered in 1936 in Baerwolf,
the monsters and the critics
talking argued the monsters,
Grendel,
Grendel's mother and the Dragon,
or not merely extraneous to the narrative,
but should be a focus of study.
Talking believed critics,
but too much emphasis on the
historical elements of the tail.
Instead of looking at it
as a work of art as Oxford,
talking to friends and colleagues,
cs Lewis,
best known for his fantasy series,
the chronicles of Narnia,
the two men bonded over their shared
love of mythology and it's began meeting
regularly for a glass,
a joke,
and to criticize each other's poetry.
The meetings were so enjoyable and useful,
they invited others to join.
The informal group known as the inklings,
eventually grew to 19 members and to
the mass once a week late at night,
sometimes not wrapping up until two or
three o'clock in the morning as well as
the practice talking shared manuscripts
of works in progress with the inklings
and received energetic
feedback from the group.
Among other ratings.
Talking brought original poetry
sections from the Hobbit,
excerpts from the notion club papers
and each new chapter of the Lord of the
rings.
There is little evidence to support the
suggestion by some that the men had a
more spiritual purpose to them.
Meetings,
the inklings continued to
meet regularly for 19 years.
Together with talking and Louis,
some of the more distinguished members
of the infant's included Neville
Cockatiel,
Hugo Dyson,
Owen Barfield and Charles Williams.
In 1945 talking changed as chair at
Oxford do the Merton professorship of
English language and literature.
He held this position until
his retirement in 1959
one hot summer day in 1928 professor
talking was grading exam papers,
which he described as soldiers drying.
He came upon a blank page and without
thought wrote down in a hole in the
ground.
They lived a Hobbit,
us,
what was a hobbit and why
did it live in the grounds?
Well talking,
you need to define the
answers to these questions.
He said later,
names always generate a story.
In my mind I thought I'd better
find out what hobbits were like.
Then injury,
talking fashion,
the dive headlong into the creative
process and concocted a tale to tell his
younger children and share
amongst the inklings.
In 1936 and incomplete copy of the
hobbit wound up in Susan diagonals,
hands and employee of the publishing firm,
George Allen,
and when recognizing the stories,
potential dagnall convinced talking
to finish it and complete it,
she presented it to her boss.
He then tested it out on his 10 year
old son who gave us a raving review.
Ours was published one year later in
1937 and it was an immediate test.
In fact,
it was so successful that the publisher
asked Toking if he has any similar
stories today.
Since the first publication,
the hobbit has sold more than 100 million
copies around the wells and has been
translated in over 50 languages.
So you might be wondering,
well,
what makes the hobbits so endearing?
For one thing,
it lacks female characters and it is not,
nor has it ever been politically correct.
It is also a very long tail with poetry
and unlike other children's fiction,
does not have a central child figure for
whom young readers can easily identify
with.
Although the protagonist Bilbo
Baggins is only a little hobbit,
so he does kind of acts
like a surrogate child.
Talkings colorful descriptions of middle
earth and it's complex characters,
goblins,
elves,
orcs,
wizards,
dragons,
and hobbits of course,
are richly portrayed and for all the
fantasy writers you came after talking
hardly any can say their wells were not,
at least in part,
influenced by the hobbits.
But what set the story apart is the depth
of emotion and moral courage talking
weaves into his heroic fiction.
There are examples of this
throughout the Hobbit,
including the death of Dwarf leader,
Thorin,
Okin shields.
There's also build those internal
struggle to do what's right,
betraying his friends while they tried
to reclaim the lonely mounds in from
Smok,
the dragon bill by fields and obsessive
greed has overtaken Thorin and when
builder finds the Arkenstone
the greatest treasure of all,
he decides to first hide it and then
give it to his friends procedures to be
used as a bargaining chip in the ends.
Bilbo exposes himself and
confesses because after all,
they are friends.
After talking's publication
of the hobbyist,
he presented portions of the Silmarillion
including incomplete stories of
Lithion and baron to Stanley and
when hoping for a warm reception,
but his reader Phelps the stories
when not commercially publishable,
they simply contains too much poetry.
Talking was disappointed of the news,
but soon found himself busy writing the
sequel to the hobbyist talkings opus.
What would become the Lord of the rings?
This was first published in three parts,
the fellowship of the ring,
the two towers,
and the return of the king between 1954
and 1955 it took him over a decade to
write these books and wind
son who was by now an adult,
was heavily involved in pushing a
temperamental talking to finish the books,
thinking it would be a
relatively unimpressive
release and they lost the from
the publishers grossly
underestimated the Lord of the rings.
Public Appeal,
true is had mixed reviews from damning
to glowing and everything in between.
The BBC adapted it into
12 condensed episodes,
elevating its popularity further.
Then in the mid 1960s a pirated
paperback version was released,
which caught the attention
of American readers,
sort of cults then developed based on
the new founds popularity of fantasy
literature and talking
was made a rich man.
He was not entirely happy though,
even if he was flatus,
partly because rumors circulators of
party going culture readers ingesting LSD
and reading the Lord of the rings and
indeed some overzealous fans who talking
referred to as lunatics.
We're calling his home and demanding
to know if Frodo has succeeded as his
quest,
the hobbies and the Lord of the rings
certainly receive all the glory,
but talking authored a number of other
articles and essays during his lifetime,
including the monsters and
the critics and other essays.
One middle earth related work,
the adventures of Tom Bombadil editions
and translations of Middle English works
such as the [inaudible],
so gay when answer or Feo
and the pal and stories,
the Emram,
the homecoming of band,
Roth band,
Roth's son and stories,
the Emram,
the layer of outro and Itron Pharma
Giles of Ham leaf by Niggle and Smith of
which a major following his death,
the letters from Father Christmas were
released by the Talkeetna state and later
son Christopher saw to edge that his
father Silmarillion and a number of other
incomplete writings under the title
of unfinished tales of Numa norm.
Men's middle f published after his
retirement from Oxford talky and moved to
Bournemouth.
And on November the 29th
71 the love of his life.
Edith died nearly two years
later on September the
second 1973 talking followed.
There's a final testament to their
love and at talking's instruction,
they were buried in a single
grave on their tombstone.
Baron is engraved under
his name and Lithion.
IPS under Edith
talking shall remain a celebrated literary
figure through the ages as his life
work continues to inspire the
fantasy genre around the world.
His characters and places have become
the namesake of various street names,
companies,
mountains,
pants and objects.
There are even asteroids named after
Bilbo Baggins and talking himself in
England that all seven blue plaques
that commemorates places associated with
talking,
talking was made a commander of the
British empire by Queen Elizabeth in 1972
and z holds a number of other
achievements and awards,
including an honorary degree from the
National University of Ireland and the
University of Legion 1954 and the Lucas
award for the best fantasy novel for the
Silmarillion in 1978 and the two
thousands talking ranked on bbcs greatest
Britain's list and the Lord of the rings
was the Uks best love novel in 2003 and
his ranks among the hundred greatest
British novels in 2015 Tolkien was placed
sixth on the list of the
50 greatest British writers
since 1945 published by the
Times in 2008 in 2009 he was listed as
the fifth top earning dead celebrities by
Forbes from 2001 to 2003 new line cinema
release the Lord of the rings as a
trilogy directed by Peter Jackson.
The series was extremely successful and
won numerous Oscar's from 2012 to 2014
Warner brothers and new line
cinema released the Hobbit,
a series of three films
based on the Hobbit book,
the first in 2012 the Hobbit,
an unexpected journey.
The second in 2013 the hobbit to the
desolation of Smaug ans the final
installment in 2014 the Hobbit,
the battle of the five armies talkings
middle earth is surely the gift that
keeps on giving and it is quite amazing
considering he wrote it all in his spare
time.
So I really hope you enjoyed
that episode of biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put out brand new videos
every Monday and every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and
subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on Youtube.
If you actually want to get a
notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to
the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time,
every Monday and Thursday
when we put out a new video.
Also,
if you want to watch
something else right now,
stuff from the archive
over there on the right,
and as always,
thank you for watching.